yes you read that title correctly
malware for max has been on the rise
according to a study conducted by atlas
vpn
showing malware development absolutely
exploding last year
over 10 times higher than the prior year
so in this video
i'm gonna explain exactly what malware
is
i'm gonna explain the issues that it can
cause
and then i'm gonna talk about if you
should actually be worried
and what you should ultimately do about
it according to this chart
cyber criminals have apparently created
an average of
1847 malware threats every day
in 2020 basically the most we've ever
seen
on mac os so if you don't know what
malware is
let me explain malware basically stands
for malicious
software and malicious is defined as
something
intending to do harm so basically
malware is any piece of software which
is
intentionally designed to harm damage
or steal data from a computer now one of
the big issues with malware is that once
it infects a computer
it begins to spread and cause even more
damage
which can lead to your computer really
starting to slow down
or even losing some of your data way
back in the day when i used to build and
use windows pcs
i struggled with this issue quite often
with malware slowing the entire pc down
giving you random pop-ups of stuff you
shouldn't be seeing
and even worse locking the entire pc
up and trying to get you to pay money
for some fake antivirus software
forcing you to completely wipe and
reinstall windows to finally get it
fixed
it definitely wasn't a fun experience
but with that said
should you be worried about malware on
your mac
well the same study i talked about
earlier also tested windows computers
and the difference is shocking as you
can see last year there were over
90 million new windows malware threads
created
which is over 135 times the amount
that were created last year for the mac
even though it was the highest year
basically ever for apple and just
looking at the windows chart in general
you can see that apple has always been
much more secure
so let me explain why apple has always
had
a huge focus on security and privacy
so let's start with that apple products
are very unique in the industry
because they continue to get software
updates for many many years
like for example you can still download
the latest ios 14 software update
for the iphone 6s which is now over
5 years old and on the mac you can
download big sur
on macs going all the way back to 2013
and making it even better they continue
to give you security updates on macs
that are even older than that for
example they just released new security
updates
for the old mac os catalina and mojave
software versions and on top of that mac
os
itself is just a whole lot more secure
most changes to the settings and
security options on your mac
require you to enter your password or
authenticate
to even get access to those settings
basically making it
extremely hard for any form of malware
to get into your mac and start changing
settings or deleting files
on windows you don't have that so many
people had issues with
viruses literally taking over control
of their computers apple also has
security in place for third-party apps
downloaded off of the internet
where you have to go into the settings
and manually unlock the privacy section
to even open the app which is something
that windows
doesn't do apple's latest macs also have
built-in
encryption which encrypts the drive and
keeps your data secure
so going back to the chart there's a
reason why there's such a huge
difference
between the amount of malware on mac os
versus
windows since apple has always been so
secure
it was never worth it to make malware
for the mac
because you could end up spending a
bunch of time writing the malware code
and never get anywhere instead if those
malware developers focused on windows
the return on investment would be much
much
higher so that's exactly what happened
it seems like the only reason we're
seeing
a big spike within the last year is
because malware developers can now
purchase
ready-made malware code and simply
adjust it to their needs instead of
starting from scratch
but the good news is that apple has
recently been making huge advancements
in security and privacy
and they're not stopping anytime soon a
couple of years back
apple updated safari with a new feature
called intelligent tracking prevention
which basically stops advertisers from
using cookies
to track you across the web and
apparently it's been doing an
absolutely excellent job at protecting
your privacy
like causing an ad firm to lose as much
as 25 million dollars
in advertising revenue and more recently
apple's added
a small little icon on your iphone that
shows when an app is accessing your
microphone or your camera
and many apps have already been caught
snooping in
on users privacy in the background and
now apple is forcing developers to add a
new
app data privacy label on every single
app on the app store
forcing them to disclose exactly what
they're tracking on your phone
which helps make iphones even more
secure going even deeper
apple recently added a new pop-up when
an advertiser or app
wants to track you across the web which
basically started a war between apple
and facebook
and long story short apple is winning
and facebook is starting to give in
so this shows just how serious apple has
been recently
in terms of security and privacy
but now i want to focus a bit more on
the mac
going back to that chart you'll notice
that the amount of new malware being
developed in 2021
has dropped significantly only around
2500 so far this year this basically
shows that the huge numbers last year
were probably an anomaly and i
personally think that the malware
developers
are leaving for one specific reason so
let's get right into that
as most of you know apple is going to
transition all of their macs over to
their own
apple silicon chips and if you didn't
already know what that is
apple is basically taking an iphone chip
suping it up and then putting it into a
mac
so the new m1 max literally have
very powerful custom iphone chips inside
of them
and as we know iphones are incredibly
secure being very very difficult
to hack into in fact they're so secure
that the fbi often has issues breaking
into iphones
when doing investigations and apple
refuses to help them
because of their dedication to the
privacy of their customers
going as far as to deny the fbi going
further
the app store is also really secure
since it has very strict guidelines for
app development
compared to the android store which will
basically accept
any app out there and in a recent
security comparison done by nordvpn
the iphone 1 and basically every
category
being much more secure and all of that
incredible security
from the iphone is now moving over to
the mac
with the new apple silicon chips the
major benefit to this is that apple now
has
full control over the software the chip
and the mac hardware all at the same
time
making it more secure than ever before
in the past
max had a ton of security flaws due to
the intel chips
like meltdown spectre zombie load and
much more and now that apple has finally
ditched intel
they never have to worry about that ever
again and on top of that
the new m1 max now come with built-in
system integrity
and data protection features and apple
is
just getting started so basically the
new transition to apple silicon chips
is the best thing to happen to apple
security in a very long time
which is going to make it even harder
for malware to succeed and
that's why i think the malware numbers
dropped so fast
going into 2021. so with that said if
you currently own
an m1 mac or you're planning on buying
one soon
or maybe one of the future m1x models
don't worry about this whole malware
thing at all
now if you have an intel-based mac
honestly
you probably shouldn't worry about it
either we've been using them at the
office
and at home for the past seven years and
literally have
never experienced any problems with
malware or viruses
being such a small problem that i've
personally forgotten about malware
ever since i switched to a mac but if
for some reason
you're still worried about it there are
some antivirus apps out there
like clean my mac x which i think is one
of the best apps out there for taking
care of your mac
and no they're not sponsoring this video
their app is just really clean
and easy to use but to be completely
honest
i don't think that you're gonna need it
because mac os has always been
very secure and it's about to get even
better
once this apple silicon transition is
complete so finally to answer
the original question no you should not
be worried about your mac
getting malware so hopefully you learned
something new from this video
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one